mein thema ist aber eigentlich gar nicht
mein thema sondern mich haben studenten
der pädagogischen hochschule ludwigsburg
angeschrieben sie haben einen langen
brief geschrieben erst mal vielen dank
dafür dass sie sich so viel mühe gemacht
haben weil sie etwas stört ihr uni
alltag ist stark beschädigt der grund
ist sie sind nicht geimpft und sie haben
sie jetzt hilfe suchen an mich gewandt
oder besser in dieses format hier ob wir
darüber sprechen können wie es sein kann
dass sie eigentlich jetzt nicht mehr
richtig zur uni gehen können dürfen sie
natürlich aber es kostet geld diese
studenten sind nämlich nicht geimpft sie
haben sich freiwillig gegen eine impfung
entschieden und sind nicht geimpft das
bedeutet da an der pädagogischen
hochschule ludwigsburg die 3g regel gilt
genesen geimpft oder getestet dass sie
jedes mal für eine präsenzveranstaltung
den test mitbringen müssen der reguläre
test kostet 15 euro der an der uni fünf
euro hochgerechnet da sie drei
präsenzveranstaltung im monat haben sind
das 80 euro man selbst weiß noch wie es
als student bei 80 euro im monat sind
jetzt mal nicht wenig geld und die
studenten fordern nichtmals dass sie die
tests nicht mehr selbst zahlen müssen
sie fordern lediglich dass sie
vielleicht selber tests mitbringen
dürfen die dort unter aufsicht gemacht
werden denn die test an der
pädagogischen hochschule ludwigsburg die
dürfen sie auch nicht mehr danach
benutzen also nur für die
präsenzveranstaltungen in der uni müssen
sie fünf euro zahlen ich würde aber
weiter gehen als zu studenten die tests
an hochschulen müssen umsonst sein weil
bildung darf kein geld kosten vor allem
auch nicht wegen auflagen der stark
einfach mal so verfügt hat für die
hochschule nena also du hast von 80 euro
gesprochen ich habe noch zudem
hochgerechnet ja derzeit einstudiert das
sind 160 mark in der tat das war den
standort her sehr viel geld ist es heute
für viele studien immer noch 80 euro von
daher wundert mich dass du dann auch
schärfer ist als die studenten selbst
denn eigentlich ist ja klar der staat
hat jede mine impfangebot gemacht über
viele viele monate und ich weiß gar
nicht warum jetzt plötzlich tests sollen
wieder kostenlos sein sollen denn
kostenlos ist kein test ein test kostet
geld die frage ist nur wie zeit ist und
wenn die studenten selbst den test nicht
bezahlen dann bezahlen wir hier am tisch
ja und das ist ja die frage muss das
eigentlich sein ist das in ordnung ja
ich werde sie auch schimke hans ulrich
jörges und finde ich toll dann machen
wir doch dann machen wir so super dann
sammeln wie doch jetzt gleich ihr legt
eure hunderte auf den tisch und dann
schickt sie alle
oder auch patenschaften aber die hand
aber meinen die forscher ich will ja
eigentlich die sendezeit wirklich den
studenten schenken und ihr vorschlag ist
ja ein anderer die wollen ja gar nicht
auf die testserver die wollen ja die
tests die für zuhause günstiger sind
mitbringen dürfen die dort ausgeführt
werden das heißt die stände haben selber
sicher überlegt okay wie können wir die
kosten senken ohne dass die test für uns
bezahlt werden ist wie findest du in den
vorschlag ja wir haben über die sie
gerade sparen den vorschlag finde ich
absolut in ordnung und keine these und
du hast das ja noch ein ausgeführt er
die war ja dass also die studenten alles
umsonst jetzt kriegen sollen was tests
angeht und da würd ich sagen nein aber
wenn du hans ulrich jörges und du und
wie auch immer zerstören
wird übrigens ständig zusammen wird vom
staat unablässig werde ich abkassiert
und ja zahle ich das lieber als ich
andere sachen zahle aber wenn wir
unablässig jammern über die steigenden
instanzen und über die korona politik
die wieder vom tablett rutscht und so
weiter und so fort dann ist doch dass
eine der mindest bedingungen die erfüllt
werden sollen und es wird ja auch liebe
nena die neue koalition wird ja die
tests wieder kostenlos machen dann
bildet damit man einen beitrag leiste
zum eindämmen der der der der pandemie
außerdem muss ich dir mal bei der
gelegenheit sagen du hast hier mal sehr
mit vehemenz vertreten
dass die alten und pflegeheime geschützt
werden sondern staat sich gefälligst
darauf konzentriert das ist einer der
hauptpunkte in der neuen corona
vereinbarung der neuen regierung das
macht mir ein bisschen
also neue koalition an guten weg fährt
in der politik man muss es doch am ende
glaube ich auch gesamtgesellschaftlich
gesehen wozu führt diese debatte wozu
führt diese situation an der uni an der
hochschule sie führt dazu dass die
menschen weiterhin sagen werden naja ihr
wollt ja sowieso eine impfpflicht
durchsetzen der druck auf uns steigt ja
und wenn ich dann den studenten nicht
entgegen komme und sage ja klar könnt
ihr eure tests mitbringen dann führt das
dazu dass gesellschaft sich weiter
spaltet ja das weiter gestritten wird
das weiter unzufriedenheit wächst und im
übrigen was das gesundheitssystem man
geht wir haben ein solidarisches
gesundheitssystem wir zahlen alle
füreinander
ich zahle für denjenigen der geraucht
hat und lungenkrebs bekommt ja ich zahle
für denjenigen der eine besonders
anspruchsvolle sportart macht und sich
schwer verletzt wir zahlen alle
füreinander das ist unser solidarisches
system und wenn wir eine pandemie haben
und wenn wir sagen wir wollen uns
schützen dann finde ich muss der staat
diese ist aber dass
der schiffe aber wir bilden werden nicht
auch bafögs uni bauten et cetera sowieso
auch schon ohnehin mit von steuergeldern
mitfinanziert ich meinen können doch 80
euro führen für den test im monat will
serie von 100 wenn dann nur ein wahnsinn
neuer wilden aber genau das ist die
argumentation und frauchen einen ehren
es ist ja nicht so dass wir hier im geld
schwimmen und beispielsweise die
gesetzlichen krankenkassen über
überschüsse klagen das gegenteil ist der
fall die müssen gestützt werden im
nächsten jahr mit 25 milliarden aus dem
bundeshaushalt
was ich nur sagen will ist hier tun nach
zwei euro wieder kein problem ist alles
kein problem und wir zahlen als
solidargemeinschaft und natürlich ist es
toll wenn man als solidargemeinschaft
bezahlt aber man muss ich glaube ich
dann irgendwann auch einmal fragen was
kann die solidargemeinschaft alles
zahlen nochmal um die zahlen zur zeit
als solidargemeinschaft sie wir alle die
am tisch sind alle zuschauer eher zu
viel als zu wenig wir leben über unsere
verhältnisse und das bedeutet am ende
irgendjemand muss es bezahlen aber soll
jedoch auch mit offenen augen durch die
durch die welt sie sehen doch was los
ist in dieser gesellschaft sehe ich sehe
dass wir uns zurzeit viel zu viel
leisten da sehe ich und ich weiß dass
das irgendwann jemand zurück bezahlen
muss und das sind wahrscheinlich wir
oder möglicherweise unsere kinder und
deren kinder aber dann kann man dann
zwei mal anfangen wenn die neue
regierung kassensturz macht über die
wirklich wesentlichen subventionen
nachzudenken darüber so ein programm das
ist doch ein fliegen direkt gemessen an
dem was für andere zwecke ausgegeben
wird und was längst die legitimation
verloren hat das ist doch die wollen ja
auch gar kein geld haben die wollen ihre
eigenen theorien offen ist italiens
punkte ich bin ja auch eigentlich mal
dagegen dass der steuerzahler zahlt weil
es ist ja nicht wie weihnachtsmann hat
sie schon gezahlt deswegen ich bin da
eigentlich auf linie mit ja aber ich
finde ich würde mich sogar noch weiter
hinaus trauern und sagen wir haben eine
impfquote dies über 80 prozent wenn man
die chinesen noch zusammenrechnet jahren
für die korrigiert mich wenn es falsch
ist über 85 prozent brauchen da die
studie an den hochschulen überhaupt noch
dreimal die woche für jede präsenz
verschaffen wenn sie sogar nochmals
getragen einen test das ist doch jetzt
wirklich die frage und ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich finde nicht wenn aber der
staat ist ihn aufzwingt und sagen ihr
müsst euch testen drei mal die woche das
zwingt der staat auf er machen sollte
der staat macht auch ein empfang gebot
die impf der iss wird übrigens auch ja
weil das mit dem mit dem ins angebot das
wird ja auch bezahlt dass bei der parade
von unserer schimke warum hat denn dann
die cdu dafür gesorgt dass die tests
nicht mehr kostenlos sind wenn sie jetzt
sagen es wäre besser das die test
kostenlos sind gut da müssen sie
natürlich den bundesminister fragen und
die jeweiligen länder regierungen
einfach ein riesen fehler also man sagen
ja natürlich ist das ein natürlich ist
das ein punkt über den man diskutieren
muss wer a sagt muss auch b wollen die
sagen wenn wenn ich sage wir haben eine
pandemie und wir wollen dass diese
bevölkerung sie schützt dann muss ich
alles politische engagement darin
stecken dafür zu sorgen dass der virus
sich nicht verbreitet und dafür nämlich
auch geld in die hand ja wir können über
geld reden aber sie können auch an
anderer stelle vielleicht sollten wir am
ende auch nicht immer vom staat reden
sondern wirklich vom steuerzahlers macht
es glaube ich ich viel greifbarer aber
man immer wieder liest der staat der
staat nie der staat sind wir hansjörg
rates an derart wichtig er fragt sich
fraktion die regierung stellt sich am
ende hin und sagt ach wir haben das
wieder kostenlos gemacht quatsch mit
soße das hat zwar die regierung
möglicherweise kostenlos gemacht aber es
fehlten die frage ist immer im
politischen besetzen wie die prioritäten
was ist uns wichtig als land ja für
unsere gesellschaft und das ist insofern
also eine andere argumente bringen es
wird ja auch in den schulen getestet ein
paar mal pro woche je nach bundesland
aber da wird getestet glaube dreimal pro
woche werden die schüler getestet und
zwar wird das auch bezahlt weil sich
nämlich sonst die leute das gar nicht
leisten könnten und wenn die schüler als
bezahlt kriegen können verdammt noch mal
miteinander bringen das eine sind die
über 18-jährigen da sind aber ist das
ist aber nicht durchgehend wären eine
durchgängige linie im bildungssystem was
es jetzt nicht ist ja aber
beispielsweise ist der impfstoff gar
nicht zugelassen für kinder unter zwölf
das ist ja ganz klar dass die dann
getestet werden da kann man nicht sagen
ich darf dich nicht impfen aber du musst
ein test selbst bezahlen also aber ich
glaube ich
die wir bewältigen was passiert denn
jetzt weil man den studenten sagt ihr
müsst das jetzt seien 80 euro mord ich
kann dir ganz ehrlich sagen ich hätte
zwei sachen gemacht entweder ich wäre
nicht mehr zur uni gegangen zudem
präsenzveranstaltung hätte mit schreiben
lassen was schlecht für mein
bildungsniveau gewesen wäre und ich habe
auch gar nicht mehr testen auch an der
uni gilt jeder ist seines glückes
eigener schmied also ich gehe zur uni
ich möchte was lernen aber ich war ich
ja ist doch gut deswegen ist ja der
vorschlag die nie machen auch toll wir
reden ja über deine these die war ja
noch viel steiner die hatten wir heute
über die reden jahren eine steile these
da steht im papier der der neuen
koalition ich muss ich muss ich ja nicht
gut
ich würde wahrscheinlich genau dass das
selber machen oder das gleiche machen
und dann wird sich immer wieder
beschwert dass wir in allen uni
vergleichen in deutschland immer
wahnsinnig schlecht abschneiden ja im
gegensatz zur internationalen
universitäten und das ist ja nichts was
dazu beiträgt dass wir besser werden